Aufsteigende Rauchwolken, Kampfflugzeuge an
der türkisch-syrischen Grenze: Türkische
Kampfflieger bombardieren mutmaßliche Stellungen
der kurdischen Volksverteidigungseinheiten
(YPG) im Norden Syriens.
Der Einsatz „Olivenzweig“ ist vom türkischen
Regierungschef
Binali Yildirim mittlerweile bestätigt.
Zuvor hatte Präsident Recep Tayyip Erdogan
in Kütahya den Militäreinsatz angekündigt.
"Der Einsatz gegen die Stadt Afrin hat de
facto begonnen.
Als nächstes ist Manbidsch dran."
Afrin und das hundert Kilometer weiter östlich
gelegene Manbidsch
gehören zur halbautonomen Kurdenregion im Nordwesten Syriens.
Ankara will einen Zusammenschluss der Kurdengebiete
und die Entstehung einer eigenständigen Kurdenregion verhindern.
Die russische Regierung äußert sich besorgt
über die Offensive.
Das Außenministerium in Moskau ruft die gegnerischen
Parteien zur Zurückhaltung auf.